musée jardin villa château pour cette
40e édition des Journées européennes du
patrimoine le département des ivelines
vous offre un grand choix de
possibilités et comme chaque année le
château de Breteuil à choiselle organise
son traditionnel bal la demeure des
compte de Pro vous propose de plonger au
19e siècle et d'entrer dans la danse ce
qui est très original et sympathique
c'est qu'ils vont faire danser les les
spectateurs c'estd les les personnes qui
vienn comme ça dans le château peuvent
aussi danser et en quelque sorte
apprendre les danses de l'époque cette
année deux thématiques ont été choisies
patrimoine vivant et patrimoine du sport
en amont des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de Paris 2024 de nombreux
événements festifs mêlant les arts et le
sport ont relieu comme au Vélodrome
national de Saint-Quentin en iveline on
met en place différentes activités
sportives alors vélo évidemment avec le
cyclisme sur piste et le BMX et on ouvre
également les portes au grand public
pour visiter les installations du
bâtiment et les coulisses également au
cœur et inside de la préparation pour
les Jeux de Paris 2024 l'île de loisir
de cant an nveline propose aussi des
visites guidées à vélo samedi après-midi
de 14h30 à 16h30 toujours sur le plan
sportif le musée de la toile de jouet
organise un tournoi en famille avec du
croquet des jeux de quilles et de volant
et puis pour ceux qui sont plus adeptes
de patrimoine ancien la villa viardau à
Bougival sera inaugurée spécial ce
weekend sélectionné en 2018 par le loto
du patrimoine la demeure de la fameuse
cantatrice Pauline viardo est
aujourd'hui M connaissable